a former warehouse in downtown Los
Angeles is now home to one of the
world's largest private collections of
porcius over 20 models dating from
various decades are housed in this
two-story building
[Music]
the owner is British born Magnus Walker
he came to LA for one reason only it's
pretty simple it was sex drugs and rock
and roll I moved here as a 19 year old
back in 1986 so almost 32 years ago
recently I turned 50 so I spent 19 years
of my life in Sheffield England that's
where I grew up the steel town but as a
kid I always dreamt of America I watched
a lot of American TV shows such as
Starsky and Hutch Dukes of Hazzard and
always had an affiliation for America in
Los Angeles always loved Americana
American music Evel Knievel and I
suppose it was my destiny to end up in
LA it's the place that I call home and
the warehouse really was his home he
used to live right here on the upper
floor but those days are over
no I no longer live here I live right
around the corner this became a
full-time film location so it actually
made more sense to financially not live
here so what started out purely as an
accident became basically my day job for
me Porsche is a hobby it's not a
business what pays my bills is Hollywood
the film location and by that I mean we
rent the building out that we're
starting to production companies for
commercial filming of TV shows music
videos film reality still shoe and TV
commercials so ironically I'm in the
film location business and the Porsche
hobby is just a passion project for me
like I say it's not a business I don't
build customer cars I'm just an
enthusiast like everyone else that loves
Porsche loves to build loves to collect
and ultimately loves to drive I always
say it doesn't matter what language you
speak whether it's English German or
Japanese we all speak Porsche
as befits a real enthusiast Magnus
Walker also has his own garage in which
he and fellow mechanics work on the cars
second poster I ever owned is the one
I'm most associated with he's card
number 277 he started life as his 71 911
T that's the car I've done all my trike
days my club racing all my spirited
drives he's someone that's in most of
the videos and magazine articles my 1971
911 T is my favourite Porsche and you
can see why whenever he can
Magnus gets behind the wheel and takes
it out for a spin in and around LA
because he believes that Porsches are
made to be driven
just the greatest thing that's what I
love about Porsche and that's why this
is my favorite car it covers all the
senses looks good feels good smells good
tastes good and it sounds too
[Music]
I hunt and I bought cars all over the
world I've actually recently acquired
two cars from Sydney Australia so it's a
global thing cars go all over the world
and I'm able to find them and bring them
back here to the warehouse in downtown
LA these are all 911 zones so my
ultimate goal when it comes to Porsche
and sports cars is to am one of
everything the Porsche has ever made in
a sports car so the new Quest is
front-engine mid-engined rear engine
both air and water cooled so that's nine
to four nine to eight nine four four
nine six eight on the front engine
transaxle water-cooled 914 and came in
on the mid-engine and then one of every
generation of 911 for me I always have
this mantra that says I expect the worst
and hope for the best you know I'm not
interested in low mileage concours type
of cars I'm interested in driver quality
type of cars so it doesn't really matter
every car I've ever owned needs some
sort of work and my own personal
attention and details and touches put to
the car so for me as long as it cause
something I'm interested in it doesn't
matter whether it runs or drives if I'm
interested in it it's desirable to me
that's all that matters some people
might not even consider the wrecks
sitting outside cars anymore but with a
lot of love and elbow grease this urban
outlaw as Walker calls himself
restores them to their former glory
yeah I mean urban outlaw a term really
this just I live in an urban environment
I tend to do things a little bit outside
of the norm if you look at the word
outlaw it means someone that lives
beyond the rules of the law and like I
said what we some things my own way and
even when it comes to driving I describe
myself as a spirited driver the cars
that I've built a sort of hotrod outlaw
interpretations of what I like to call
sport purpose readable track cars so
urban out was just a term living in the
urban environment and doing something a
little bit different in an outlaw style
and just like the sound of the guitar
the roar of a Porsche is music to his
ears
[Music]